hello and welcome to this video playing
gone goodnight mister tom ok so let's
see I'm trying out the Sicilian but
people don't play into what I want them
to play this is not bad of course
I will never actually played a bad move
order them somehow looks like why should
be better really okay takes the delight
yeah i would like to I'd like to go to
file but I probably have to prepare it
otherwise I'm getting caught in the
center area with my team ok
yeah that looks good for white really
does kill us 25 it's very disturbing
really yes probably that move all our
models wasn't all that great somehow
maybe 96 m maybe 96 wasn't good we'll
see I mean okay this is not like losing
for me but it's um it just looks quite
uncomfortable with the pins and play
some a disadvantage that I have yeah
that was the idea and it's a bit looser
language need to develop yeah an Audi 5
is pretty much mandatory otherwise I'm
just too weakened well maybe it won't Oh
anyway um here the f5 plan is definitely
the way to go
yeah I want to prepare all that a little
bit better intense and bring the night
to see form it yep I can do this and
then at five I mean it's not not ideal
probably not bad either should be active
in love him look look to c 6 something
that is disturbing something that you
can do even at the cost of an exchange
are you and it counter play badly Luke
is coming to have seven and I mean we
have to do something about h4
not sure what the best is here h3 or f3
stop the same so this is a ship seat
with the temple and then potentially
Bishop to b6 okay I need to be click
here like he might come under fire of
course with all those poor moose but
again CL most probably don't do it yeah
so here I was thinking Bishop takes an
h4 h 3 being the idea
yeah probably all the way back
so you threatening just to take it it's
that's not nice
yeah maybe here doesn't that looks
completely wrong but what can you do
Bishop d7 blunders to form and other
other squares looked looking worse
very shaky position it's extremely
likely to be good for white okay now i
can check i don't know if that helps but
and then King to h2 to have some self
painting quality jnh for Navy cannot
take a seven maybe that works actually
here like bishop f2 and then look at 74
temple now F to Hanks as well and might
have untangled here from this very bad
probably very bad position
yeah okay no f2 and how do I take it and
both both rooks do make sense some
somehow this looks more active because
it gets the pin celeste the pin going
yeah now roots the age I was thinking
this is an interesting move time one
each of these five is made that's a mate
as the g pawn is pinned forex EA doesn't
work and creepy XD form yeah now here I
am there are tons of checks I can win
the Queen up with with this can I do
something better okay let's get in the
Queen and then this is infected I'm air
for then I hoped of the Queen up I was
thinking however that I still have
chances to checkmate this is the thing
there are checkmating ideas here
he'll be wonderful item plus it's an
intense therapy one is the end I think
this was a maid maid in something you
can gather conch as well so let's have a
look there I was definitely in some
trouble maybe that's what losing it
looked it was really bad after you got
this invasion going here I felt I should
be okay but maybe I played it wrong
things I felt his bishops aren't that
great either are not that minor good but
computers on roughly equal evaluation
that doesn't yeah this this was probably
wrong I'm 23 now things look grim
somehow yeah I'm shifty one was giving
me now I'm back in the game amazing and
now if was winning so it wasn't that bad
yeah i mean at least i will be totally
losing which are somehow expected to be
and it looked so shaky but it wasn't
that bad it seems a very tough to play
with this limited time okay thanks for
watching